[Music]
virtus pro CS team is impossible to hate
completely deconstructing fnatic here
the Polish roster was one of the most
beloved in counter-strike they defined
an era through their skill and their
personality the team stuck together for
four years through the good times and
the bad but now it's all over yeah
that's it in this shot
get right comes in and smashes snacks
against the wall that's the end of VP
hair really I think the story is
certainly gonna fall onto vpm what
really is going to be you know their
future about what is going to happen
next
good things come and good things go
[Applause]
Hey but before we get into it if you
want a cool before eSport branded shirt
like the one I'm wearing or plenty of
others like it you can find them to
score eSports online March departments
to find a link in the comments below
they're going to go to the lost Jon
salute
[Applause]
for the customers on Fitness pro they
are playing the perfect kind of striped
games
verda throws polish roster was one of
the longest handing five-man squads in
csgo made up of a handful of players
from a legendary 1.6 roster nicknamed
the golden five they were signed by vp
early on in csgo to lifespan and earned
a new nickname the furnace plow I think
when you look at versus Pro it was just
this was a combination of things main
one for me was how they played as a team
they had like really strong team play
people would always talk about the plow
and their T side well that comes from
them being a very well oiled machine
it's not entirely clear with the name
came from we call them the varnish ball
for a reason because it's nearly
impossible to stop them when they get
going
but the most scary aspect is every now
and then a different verse Pro appears
they bought all the Lightning and
suddenly they're on top of it
it's a diverters plow everyone talks
about but for the most part the virtus
plow worked in tandem with the virtus
throw they were a legendarily
inconsistent team either plowing over
their opponents like it was nothing or
losing to them so badly it was almost
like they were throw that's 11 - this is
getting to the point of no return I have
to say and there's a tea salad man for
sure BP definitely no slouches on their
tee sides
okay then well 14:8 hellraisers are
somehow making constant tasters
he's evaded it's gonna be a situation Oh
stay alive don't lose the weapon even
worse insult to injury how's the salt
how's the wound bleed it out don't care
you just lost a 12:30 a half after
winning the pistol on the second is well
virtus pro
this is awful me Ali's gonna try and put
this into overtime on all fairness the
game should have been done ages ago
hellraisers with an incredible comeback
for what the 6th time from a 12 3 half
this year that is just unbelievable
12 3 and you win the pistol 13 3 up and
you lose 16 14 aliens
The Plough featured Potter by theft has
Neos snacks and B alley
it remained unchanged for years aside
from contemporary fandom from fellow
poles Michou morels mints and elixir yes
Olaf Monster is here alright guys can be
huge for most hunting the team first
started playing together under ESC
gaming in 2013 from there the roster
signed with Universal soldiers before
playing under the again banner one that
previously hosted the golden by virtus
Pro already had a csgo roster one good
enough to end ni P's 87 map lane win
streak but they dropped it in 2013 in
January 2014 virtus Pro signed the
entire again roster when they decided to
make another run in cs:go the team was
known for their very strong P side and
their incredible teamwork was first
though
the key man in that beam site and
furnace row are gonna win themselves as
the crowd
and it's 39 they now need just three to
be the EMS champions third is pro have
to kneel in the bombsite trying to
Pompey all he puts a hedgehog to exist
and it's jolly to hold on to that site
with the help of spec caches there as
well
have to save five match points there SIA
skills may have been what built up those
five lovable poles reputations but it
was their personality the Kempe fans at
their peak they were playing the
absolute best CS but their valleys
didn't really look that good as well no
when the group stage for us but it has
every time but when we passed the groups
we always show our best dream AK winter
2013 was the first ever csgo major and
of course the cores first major together
the poll showed up under that Universal
soldiers tag and left the tournament
with a 9th 12th finish but they
rebounded in only three months they went
from that underwhelming performance to
the top of the CS world and he'll push
in to see T's fold and he'll look for a
second ladies and gentlemen have no
doubt neo is back in business
stacks gets an excellent
ni pf2 on five they are in real trouble
here as virtus Pro they won their first
major together at ESL one Katowice on
home turf in their path to the finals
was anything but easy
in the playoffs they had to play against
the French powerhouse team ldl-c and
then the Swedish giant LGBT it's gonna
get one and can he be the man who sends
bro he waves goodbye
the Swedes 67 to vets to one well makes
the world number one team in n IP in the
grand finals VP made a light work of n
IP right in the middle of that Swedish
rosters period of dominance its fry
books telling that of fry bugs gone and
he will show himself at the right moment
which is a head shot off to be Ollie he
will eventually go down to hazard Pacha
they're three francs away now burners
grow as they will move the ball in and
it'll be v Lehren annexes to come charge
again
[Applause]
it's all forest he gets the first he
doesn't get this
[Applause]
so look at that there are extremely
happy and I think they are even happier
eight hours
the whole
verda throat now had a major win under
their belt solidifying their legacy
early on in cs:go history but their
impressive win and cut a visa aside VP's
out of game personality almost eclipsed
their CS play who their memorable quotes
hilarious quick streams and on camera
antic VP created a connection with CS
fans all around the world pass share
what's going through your head right now
I dream about Lamborghini if you are
learning just like me go to pass along
the school that's when I'm at my best
but my boys today play [ __ ] super
awesome you know all right
I know the word it's did you have a
system you waiting in a BB like cyber
way degrading smoke to stop by by Nico
Nico you can come in as fu if you agree
or disagree if you'd like waiting in the
smoke we top that bad counter Hacha is
the best known of the five boasting a
stream packed with memorable quotes and
moments his role as the team's primary
offer is almost a side note and he's
often seen as the face of the team he
also knows how to rock the camp fire
these even be bigger on the rosy - just
waiting oh don't do it Pacha that's so
cruel he nights for sure and that will
be kids if they weren't already winning
if they weren't already completely
deconstructing fnatic here
completely styling on phonetic Hacha is
a family man
his love for assembly comes before
anything else and that's part of his
appeal but the rest of the team were
just as memorable 1.6 legends neo and
has had been playing together since 2004
the original golden 5 that was created
in 2006 we've been playing together for
like three and a half years and now it's
already four we've never been that
together for that long
and I've been playing with tests since
2004 and that's just that's just crazy
partial joined us in 2010 so we're like
family neo is considered one of the best
1.6 players of all time often competing
with forest for that top spot he had
such an influence on CS that the mousee
helped design with sowee
is considered standard equipment for
both bug stars and top players he
captained virtus pro during their major
win and all those premier tournament
victories over the year he's lost cream
C's in the corner trap it's a one on so
they're coming in from either side
adoption and so much job is gonna go
down and
ladies and gentlemen with 16 routes they
are no easy season one Grand Champion
how fitting to see neo lift that trophy
as well if it's so long they've been in
a slump
[Applause]
roster in cs:go today they've been
when other teams decide to change it up
no VP they stick together they work it
all out and now they're standing at the
top again has also assisted in the igl
duties and brought a level of a
leadership to the team come on guys it
was a great match you have to cheer for
both teams in great matches like that
told me through what was it like to play
what's hard than unfitted to play that
game but guys respect for that final ii
find that it's beef we spank them
amazing were sometimes amazing was
that's what makes this point great
snacks in the alley were young unproven
talent when they joined the team but
have certainly carved their own legacies
since then and to just snacks
that's fine one arm let's not leave him
out of this the Big Apple and snacks is
hungry he's got one kill already of the
USP low HP as well on Guardian and flame
he's trying to get by
I've never seen anything like at what
the house
the map essentially playing a retake on
the a bomb site see it looks like that's
what we've here up to here for clim
headshot from my Alianza pronax and he's
looking for more they're getting close
now he's got one more shot and that just
might be VP in the grand finals but
despite some slumps in the years
following their major win VP did have
some success stories too they were
always able to get it done in to Europe
with first place finishes starladder
i-league invitational 1 and copenhagen
games 2015 and there's gonna be a man in
my brain has no idea he's gonna top it
just like that
both pills and virtus pro after losing
to NIV last year have come back the
copenhagen games to reclaim a title vp
took first place finishes at a league
season won Dreamhack Bucharest 2016 and
Dreamhack Las Vegas 2017 and VP always
showed up at the major usually placing
third fourth but even reaching as high
as second at the Elia Atlanta major but
for a team so used to success so proven
on the game's biggest stages the slums
were pretty hard to overlook the big
problem versus Pro faces is that at the
moment even they're living off the
storyline like they want to say well we
always find a way to come back you know
and it's the big game we always turn up
again but it's never been as bad as this
like in the past when they had slumps it
was mainly online tournaments so it was
the odd offline tournament they're
looking at a solid we're talking about
four or five months since they were
actually relevant as a team that could
win a big tournament and now they're
trying to win the biggest after Atlanta
virtus Pro were relegated out of the ESL
pro league and into the Mountain Dew
League which was a massive deal they're
forced to play with academy teams and
tier two squads becoming only the second
major winning roster to do so after
gambit and even I was at a pro league VP
kept performing very poorly their only
win after allegation came from the
adrenaline Cyber League a small for team
Russian LAN event their next large event
was ESL one cologne 2017 where they
placed 50
sixteenth with a Krakow major just
around the corner
VP had just one chance left to show
signs of life we're all tied up here in
the first half on second back of this
quarter final beat you easily won oh the
team surprised at everyone making it all
the way to semies in front of their home
crowd it was seen as a glimmer of
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
somebody's going to get impatient well
that works actually
maybe VP had what it took to make a
comeback maybe they were in just one of
their characteristic slumps and they
make their way back up to the top of the
csgo world only a few months later they
placed second at epicenter 2017 and the
starladder i-league invitational - which
lend some credence to that theory but it
wouldn't last
the results are to slip and vp entered
another one of their classic swamps but
this time they couldn't pull out 2018
started with a weak 15th 16th finish at
the Boston major and there's a lot
player passion in the red there he goes
and there they go
virtus Pro have been eliminated from the
major cloud minor fighting for survival
we could see you know the hitch between
the two teams is gonna mean a lot for
cloud 9 some members of the community
had a long been saying that was time for
a change on VP's roster but the team was
reluctant to do it finally them after
months of poor results the team started
to fall apart in February 2018 in the
last past years I was good sometimes was
better sometimes was [ __ ] we break our
schedule in last year and two years ago
we did like different things like we
usually didn't so what is my main like
my main point why we lost why we start
losing we have like this experience we
have a lot of times so if you win one
even with me though we come back and we
will be in the top teams like for for a
larger VP benched has it was the first
major roster move the lineup had made
since they became furnace pro he left
the team in March and went on to captain
another polar squad team King would
shortly after that the team removed Snax
he joined Matta sports for time but has
since become a free agent and prior to
the London major the team announced that
regardless of the outcome it would be be
Ally's last
and with that the verdict I'll family
that we all came to know in a love came
to an end it was an end of an era for
the Polish brothers illness we needs
five other guys who wake up in you know
in positive energy like individuals to
heal the highest level not free people
play play good means five five guys who
is in the top level cards right these
days and to show you know the best
everything if you mean to play the final
in the study we need to solve the best
cancer strike in the world neo and Pasha
are the last remaining members of BP's
occasional lineup but even Pasha whose
play has begun to slip has hinted that
he's ready to leave if things don't
change you know it will be nice to break
to the legends to once again have a
legend status who knows maybe it will be
my last one starting something isn't
right maybe this will be like a good
decision I think about it you know like
right now in every day every morning
every afternoon right now it's a hard
decision so but still everything this is
in my head dog can't can't consult about
think about it despite some new talent
the team just isn't the same and hasn't
been able to find that old VP success
since making those roster moves they
placed dead last at the London major and
haven't been able to put up a notable
result at a premier tournament since no
matter how you look at it this is the
end of an era versus probe are
eliminated from the major in London and
North score continue on for now at the
very least another page in a book for
versus probes but this chapter is
blessed virtus Pro was the longest
standing csgo roster and they brought
the community years of laughter and
heartwarming moments we are like
familiar we want change line
yeah like I said we are family so that's
make us better than other teams I think
we we know each other a long time now so
like I said I think it said advantage
for us don't care about everything love
sport family is for sometimes food car
you catch up on all of the eSports news
and my friends coming to you coming and
we we can we can go to the pathos folio
in Katowice it's private private lessons
in our room you can always come I feel
like I'm surrounded by three jokes and
neo just like the kids are at it again
Leo are you got any final words I have
nothing to it
through it all those five players stuck
together whether they find success under
new team or not the magic that gave us
the plow is well and truly gone but for
the fans who loved virtus Pro the ride
was worth it
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]